please professor Wiseman thank you so
much thank you I'm going to stand up
because i'm a professor i'm used to
standing up ah she's a young professor
i'm going to talk to you about a very
different type of data that I've been
gathering very different data from what
we've seen the rest of the day and that
is simply the content of regulations
since 2008 when I began working at the
University of Texas I've been attempting
to collect data on just the content of
regulations in approximately 16
different states in most of the shale
formations to determine simply how
states are approaching the issue of
shale gas I've also been collecting data
on the violations at well sites that
have involved hydraulic fracturing I
have attempted to identify regulations
at almost every stage of the well
development process so I'm actually
won't talk much about hydraulic
fracturing at all today everything from
seismic testing to construction of the
well site drilling casing cementing the
well storing waste and surface pits
disposing of them in underground
injection control wells or through
wastewater treatment plants and then
also just storing and disposing of
flowback water in particular so in 10
minutes I'll tell you all about those 16
different states here we go we're
primarily at the state level for several
reasons there are important federal
regulations that apply to fracturing
I'll discuss them but but there are
certain federal exemptions and for the
federal regulations that do apply States
typically implement them so the Safe
Drinking Water Act is a very important
federal regulation with respect to
underground injection control disposal
wells like we heard about in Ohio
State's typically implement the federal
safe drinking water act standards it's
something we call cooperative federalism
in legal terms and then we also have
some regional regulatory bodies are
important especially in the Marcellus
region Susquehanna and Delaware River
Basin Commission's are increasingly
active in regulating shale gas
development or at least trying to and
then local governments as Professor John
Nolan will discuss are also increasingly
involved although in
cases states are trying to preempt local
regulation but states are at the center
of all of this again this is in part
because of a few exemptions it's a
politically loaded term I don't intend
it that way it's simply that in the past
Congress has determined that a certain
aspects of federal statutes and EPA
implementation of the statutes through
regulation shouldn't apply to oil and
gas one of the big exemptions is Rick
raw resource conservation Recovery Act
which applies to waste the handling of
waste from cradle to grave subtitle C of
that act which applies to hazardous
waste does not address many exploration
and production wastes from oil and gas
so the states are primarily responsible
for those wastes we also have the actual
injection of water and chemicals down
the well that's a very small phase of a
much larger process but the injection of
watering chemicals down the well the
actual hydraulic fracturing is not
regulated by the safe drinking water act
although fracturing with diesel is and
the EPA has just developed guidelines
for fracturing with diesel we have some
very important federal laws that do
apply again the Safe Drinking Water Act
governs the safety of underground
injection control wells that except
produced waters and flow back waters
from many drilled and fractured wells we
also have new a Clean Air Act standards
coming in for the volatile organic
compounds that are emitted from the
flowback water by approximately january
first 2015 operators will essentially
have to capture those VOCs and send them
through pipeline rather than letting
them out into the air I mentioned the
diesel fuel fracturing standards the
Endangered Species Act a migratory bird
treaty Zack also very important a lot of
oil and gas attorneys spend their time
trying to figure out how to prevent
Golden Eagles from roosting on rigs as
well as keeping birds out of surface
pits there have been some interesting
prosecutions recently in the Bakken
Shale by the Fish and Wildlife Service
dead ducks were found in the surface
reserve pits
a federal court however said that there
was not a direct killing of the Ducks by
the oil and gas company in the Bakken so
the prosecution's were reversed but
Texas the federal courts in Texas
disagree with that determination storm
water permits we've talked a little bit
about sediment and erosion when an oil
or gas site is constructed the operator
must obtain a federal Clean Water Act
permit called a stormwater nip T's
permit typically state implemented and
then finally the EPA is developing clean
pretreatment standards for flow back and
other liquids waste sent from shale gas
wells to wastewater treatment plants but
the states are the most important and
let me just briefly go through some of
the major stages of well development and
give you a few examples from the state's
various states are attempted to
essentially regulate nuisances
associated with shot holes or the vibra
size operations a thumper buggy or some
other equipment hits the ground to
create the vibrations that we heard
about earlier today and essentially you
want to separate those operations from
houses in some cases from water water
wells this Colorado regulation is for a
shot hole you've basically to fill in a
shot hole if you dynamite the hole and
you have to rake around it basically
restore the site to its previous
condition Maryland might even deny a
vibro size permit or shot hole hole
permit if it could substantially damage
the environment and someone asked about
cutting of trees earlier Arkansas
actually prevents the cutting of trees
for vibra size or shot whole operations
trees that are six inches or more in
diameter in terms of building the access
road and the well site very interesting
requirements for setting back well sites
from various protected resources this is
one of the best ways to prevent
contamination especially if an
accidental surface spill occurs Colorado
has these buffer zones in which only
limited oil and gas drilling or
fracturing activities may occur around
water supplies and they have various
controls required within this buffer
zones
examples of other setbacks I'd say Texas
has been the least aggressive on the on
the setback front it basically only
requires the setting back of a well from
houses but in other states you see
requirements for separating Wells from
public water supplies streams wetlands
and the like a lot of discussion about
baseline testing today Colorado just
came out with a new regulation
environmental groups have criticized it
because it actually caps the number of
wells and water sources that may be
tested before oil and gas drilling
occurs but it does require baseline
testing Pennsylvania and West Virginia
have a very interesting provision a
rebuttable presumption that the
contamination of water within a certain
distance of an oil or gas site was
caused by the oil grass operation what
does that do strongly incentivizes
baseline testing by the company right
because if there's going to be a
rebuttable presumption the company wants
some way to rebut the assertion that
water was contaminated Pennsylvania has
recently expanded that presumption Ohio
has mentioned requires baseline testing
within 1500 feet of unconventional wells
and it has interesting requirements for
whether the testing must occur sort of
down gradient of the oiler or gas site
Michigan also requires a hydrogeological
investigation within 1300 feet but many
states don't require any baseline
testing casing has been mentioned that
every state requires surface casing this
is an incredibly important part of the
well development process the depths of
the casing required the depths of the
surface casing below ground water vary a
bit for example from 30 feet to 100 feet
many states require that the piping used
for the casing be new or that if it is
used and thus could potentially be
compromised it must be tested to show
that the casing will be adequate other
states appear to allow just used casing
they don't specify so high 04
we'll just says steel production casing
Oklahoma set says oilfield grade steel
casing and moving quickly honored
onwards cementing this first bullet is a
little bit compressed there are two
separate regulations for cementing one
is that the cement must reach a
compressive strength in a certain time
another's the cement must stand for a
certain amount of time before testing or
other interruption of the welker's that
ensures is a cement with between the
casing and the wellbore will set
properly and I assume I'm running out of
time so let me just tell you there there
are lots of different regulations in
States although increasingly I think
we're starting to see uniformity states
are changing some of their regulations
as they're looking at approaches
elsewhere water withdrawals for
fracturing some states require permits
and a promise that the in-stream flow
levels will not be affected most states
require liners and pits some states have
very good secondary containment
requirements for pits and tanks so that
if something spills a liner or some
something else underneath a tank or pit
will prevent the spill from going off
site and then finally Ohio has revised
its underground injection control well
requirements in response to the
potential earthquakes that have occurred
around the disposal wells it's requiring
mandra alright some some gaps remain
however in my brief ten-minute
exploration I can't really do justice to
this as I mentioned those states like
Texas don't really have many setback
requirements casings casing is required
in every state but organizations such as
the state review of oil natural gas
environmental regulations stronger which
is an i/o GCC group have suggested that
some state casing standards need to be
updated in light of fracturing
increasing pressure on wealth and with
that I will leave it to Professor Nolan
to discuss the local impact
and you're rich thank you